[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone so we've been
talking about systems of differential
equations and how you can simulate them
by looking at their eigenvalues and
eigenvectors how you can understand
their behavior so we've seen that
systems with stable eigenvalues that
have a negative real part
then the system X in time will be
decaying kind of a decaying exponential
function this is you know e to a minus
Lambda t
we've also seen that if we have a
positive or unstable eigenvalue we will
get kind of this unstable exponential
growth
of x
in t this is an e to the positive Lambda
T okay
[Music]
I'll show you today and this is super
duper important for a lot of problems
like turbulence and things like that
that looks a little bit different than
this so it's somewhere between these two
and the case I'm going to show you today
the state of the system initially
grows large very very large it looks
like an unstable system
but then it turns around and eventually
decays so there is a really interesting
class of systems of differential
equations
x dot equals ax
where the eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of this a matrix give rise to this very
peculiar Behavior where you get this
kind of initial this is called a
transient energy growth
transient
energy growth
energy growth
and then finally after this transient
energy growth eventually you get a
stable
Decay a stable
decay
so these systems these a matrices will
have stable eigenvalues eigenvalues with
a negative real part but through some
interesting mechanism that I'll tell you
about today they have this initial rise
of the state the state actually leaves
the origin it goes away from x equals
zero it climbs and then eventually it
slowly decays back so it's kind of a
weird mixture of these two and often
it's characterized by dynamics that look
like t e to the minus Lambda T these are
called secular terms secular kind of
means like transient or
um you know not permanent
uh and so this secular or transient
energy growth is a characteristic of
these types of of solutions
these are really
in turbulence in fluid dynamics
um because you actually have systems
that are actually stable for all time
for all
um flow configurations but you can still
observe turbulence in those systems so
for example flow past a pipe like your
garden hose or the pipes that lead to
your house
um pipe flow is linearly stable at all
flow velocities
but clearly we've all seen when you turn
on the tap at some large flow velocity
if I if I turn it on slowly maybe I have
a smooth laminar flow but when I turn it
on full blast I get this kind of
turbulent flow coming out it looks all
messy and disorganized and turbulent
and I'm going to show you today in a few
minutes that it's this transient energy
growth that is what gives rise to that
turbulence that kind of very non-linear
turbulent Behavior even for a system
that's linearly stable so I'm going to
come back to that example in fluid
mechanics in a little bit
but for now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to introduce what kind of an a
matrix has this type of property and I'm
going to show you an example in Python
and Matlab good
the kinds of systems that have this
Behavior are what are called non-normal
non-normal
I think this is a an oddly Progressive
terminology for a concept in math that's
probably quite old so these non-normal
systems
and normality is a property of this a
matrix that literally means that if a
transpose times a equals a
a transpose then this would be a normal
Matrix a would be called normal if this
is true and so a non-normal system has
an a matrix where this is not true and
specifically the more not true this is
the more different these two matrices
are the more non-normal your system is
so you can have very highly non-normal
systems and again I'll give you some
physical intuition for what non-normal
means for example in fluid mechanics and
we'll be able to compute it in in python
or in Matlab but I'm just defining there
is this test that you can do to see if
your Matrix a is normal or not and
non-normal systems often have this
transient energy growth or rather this
transient energy growth is particularly
pronounced in very non-normal systems so
I'll give you an example
um one of the examples I like to give is
what if my a matrix
was equal to
um
minus
0.009 will actually code this one up
minus 0.009 0 minus 0.01 that's the
diagonals so these are going to be the
eigenvalues and I have a 1 off diagonal
okay so this again you can read the
diagonals off of the system any system
that has zeros below the diagonal or
zeros above the diagonal then the
diagonal terms are going to be your
eigenvalues so we can read these off
that Lambda equals
minus 0.01 and Lambda equals minus 0.009
so these are in fact
this is in fact a stable system it has
stable eigenvalues I would get you know
e to the minus Lambda T type behavior in
this system so it is stable
but because of this one up here because
of the the structure of this matrix it's
eigenvectors are going to be nearly
parallel okay so that is another kind of
Hallmark signature of these non-normal
systems is that they're going to have
nearly parallel eigenvectors I'm going
to have two eigenvectors from different
eigenvalues that point almost perfectly
in the same direction okay so so all in
a minute I'll actually compute out the
eigenvectors I'll convince you that
they're nearly nearly parallel
but so these non-normal systems the way
I think about them is that they are
almost degenerate they are almost
uh
degenerate
meaning that they almost are rank
deficient if those eigenvectors were
perfectly perfectly parallel then the
determinant of you know a would be zero
and I would have a real issue okay so
I'll come back to all of that in a
minute I just want to convince you yes
this a matrix does have stable eigene
values
um
but I'm going to show you in Python and
Matlab that it has this transient energy
growth and Decay signature okay so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to fire up
the computer we're going to actually
simulate the system plot the
trajectories I'll show you that this is
the behavior you get maybe we'll even
compute how non-normal the system is
that could be you know interesting and
then I'm going to go back to paper and
pencil and you know write down the
eigenvectors show you that they're
parallel and then connect this back to
fluid systems so that's what I'm going
to do in this lecture
um okay good so let's
um turn on
uh let's see
okay it looks like I'm starting in uh in
Python here and again all of the codes
are available in Python and in Matlab so
you can just go to the website and
download these
um and this one was written by Alan
captanaglu based on my Matlab code so
again we're going to you know import
some stuff I think specifically we're
going to be integrating the Dynamics so
we're importing solve ibp from scipy's
integrate
uh and specifically here what we're
going to do is we are going to build
this a matrix it's exactly the one that
I wrote down here
we're going to start with some initial
condition
um just you know 0 1 into X1 and X2
coordinates and we're going to integrate
that system forward on some time Vector
okay so we're defining some linear ode
which is just uh X dot equals a times x
I guess here it's y dot equals a times y
it doesn't matter what we call these
variables in in Python and then we solve
this initial value problem
um of that linear ode on a certain time
range and we we integrate the solution
and then we're going to plot the
solution
okay so you should feel pretty
comfortable with this by now
and this is the actual plot the
honest-to-goodness trajectory of the X1
and X2 coordinates I guess here they're
called X and V and so the X1 and X2
coordinates one of them at least the
first state here x has this large
transient energy growth before
eventually it dies off and becomes
actually stable okay so this is just
kind of visual proof that this does
happen in these systems you actually get
this large transient growth that looks
unstable before it turns around and
comes back to the origin so this is a
globally stable system but at least
locally it doesn't look stable to start
with
okay good
um you know you can do the same thing in
uh in Matlab I'm just showing you this
here because because I have it uh same
exact thing create a Time Vector that
we're going to integrate from Time Zero
to time a thousand and increments of 0.1
build my a matrix have my initial
condition and integrate this system y
dot equals a times Y and then plot the
answer
so I'll just do that right now
and this is the answer
and again you can see oh that is way too
small let's make my line widths
um much bigger
let's make it three
it's simulating this thing it's taking a
little while
yeah that's much easier to read
and again you see this uh this this
characteristic rise in the energy before
it eventually dies out to zero so this
is an honest to goodness stable system
it is stable you compute the eigenvalues
and you say to yourself well they're you
know negative real parts of course I'm
going to have a stable system e to the
minus Lambda T
but for some reason I get this weird
transient energy growth here okay and
I'll point out that this system is when
I when I say it's almost degenerate what
I mean by almost degenerate in this case
is that if I breathed on the system if I
perturbed it a teeny tiny little bit
then these eigenvalues would exactly
equal each other I would get Lambda
Lambda 1. currently these are distinct
different eigenvalues with distinct
different eigenvectors but if I had
exactly this number equals minus 0.01 so
if I changed it by just a little bit so
that they're equal
then I will get a completely different
eigenstructure than my um
kind of all have a two-dimensional
Subspace for that eigenvac value Lambda
I'll have two eigenvectors and I'll show
you how to compute those in in the next
lecture but basically that's what I mean
is that this thing is almost degenerate
if it was you know Lambda 1 0 Lambda so
I had an actual repeated eigenvalue that
would be a degenerate system that would
give me these uh these secular terms so
I'm going to show you how to derive
these terms in the next lecture for an
actually kind of degenerate system with
repeated eigenvalues this one is just
approximately repeated eigenvalues
and I guess I could compute the
um
the eigen decomposition the IGS of a
and we find again that these eigenvalues
are very very close and more importantly
my eigenvectors are nearly parallel that
was what I was showing you before this
eigenvector points in the the one zero
Direction This eigenvector points in the
you can just multiply this by a minus
sign in the one minus 0.001 Direction so
these are very very very nearly parallel
eigenvectors they only differ by you
know 0.1 percent so they're almost in
the same direction and that's a really
big problem that's what's going to give
rise to this transient energy growth as
I'll show in a minute last thing I want
to compute is
um what is it like a transpose times a
and a times a transpose
are very very different these you know
almost couldn't be more different right
this one has a zero in the upper left
this one has a one in the upper left
this one has a one in the lower right
this one has a zero in the lower right
these are very very different matrices
so this is a highly non-normal a matrix
okay good
um so we've just plotted and
demonstrated yes in fact this Matrix has
this weird property and now we're going
to analyze further kind of why that's
true we're going to derive these terms
and we're going to connect it to some
interesting properties in fluid
mechanics
okay so let me move this out of the way
without throwing my laptop
good
um so
so we're analyzing this system I've
computed the eigenvalues let's just
compute the eigenvectors really quickly
um you know I'm going to write it down
you can um again you're basically
finding a minus Lambda I
times what Vector X
equals zero okay so for these lambdas
we're trying to find the x that maps to
zero and uh we already showed that these
um in my notes I call them C's so I'm
going to call them C's here just so I
don't confuse you if you're following
along at home so let's say this is an
eigenvector C and so the C's are at C1
equals
um
I think I might have mixed up which ones
which but C1 equals 1 minus 0.00
one
and C2
equals one zero so again these are very
very nearly parallel eigenvectors okay
and so if I multiply a matrix If I
multiply my my unit vectors remember
anytime I multiply
vectors by a matrix it usually rotates
and stretches them so what I can do is I
can take my coordinate axis let's say my
my
um
my coordinate axis and I'm going to
multiply I'm going to take a unit Vector
in the X Direction a little unit Vector
in the X Direction
and a little unit Vector in the y
direction and I'm going to multiply them
by this a matrix and I'm going to see
where they go okay
so I'm going to multiply this by a
and I'm going to draw some axes over
here we're actually going to try to plot
these things
so what is my unit Vector times a so my
first unit Vector is like 1 0. so if I
multiply this by 1 0 I get
minus a very very small number
one zero okay minus a very very small
number
in the X Direction minus 0.009 in the X
Direction and zero in the y direction so
this vector
maps to minus 0.0090
okay so this little Vector maps to a
teeny tiny vector and if I did this in
for a little unit Vector in y the 0 1
Vector that would map so if I multiply 0
1 by this I get 1 minus 0.01 1 minus
0.01 so that's a big Vector with a big a
big length
and so what we find is that this unit
Vector became teeny tiny
and this Vector
um
is almost parallel it's actually
pointing 1 in The X Direction and a
negative teeny teeny bit in the y
direction
I can't really draw it that accurately
but it looks like that
so they're nearly parallel and this
one's a lot longer than this one
and so technically if I actually Drew
the little box here you would find that
this thing is you know this box here
got massively sheared and stretched into
this very very thin rectangle here okay
and so that's what this a matrix is
doing is it's taking something that you
know vectors that are perpendicular and
it's mapping them into very very
parallel uh parallel vectors this is
called shearing this is a highly sheared
Matrix and it's a non-normal matrix it's
it's a shearing this this unit this unit
box here
okay good um so in the next lecture what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
specifically how to solve e to the a t
when this is actually degenerate when
these eigenvalues are exactly equal and
we're going to derive these secular
terms here these um I'm literally going
to call them secular secular is it
secular or secular
secular terms I don't know how to spell
it secular terms
this almost has like a religious
connotation right like the secular world
is the transient world not the uh
forever you know
spiritual terms or whatever so in the
next lecture I'm going to derive these
secular terms for an a matrix with
exactly repeated eigenvalues so I'm
going to show you how to compute e to
the a t for that Matrix and convince you
that these really are the terms but what
I'm showing you here is that even when
the eigenvalues are not perfectly equal
they're just very very close and my
eigenvectors are very very parallel I
get terms that look a lot like this and
so now what I want to do is I want to
give you some examples in fluid dynamics
so example
an example
in fluids
which is there are lots of flows that
have this basic property of
non-normality so any flow that is what's
called Shear dominated so a really good
example of this is a boundary layer flow
so you can imagine the the fluid flow
over like a Boeing Wing a you know
triple seven wing is starts off being
laminar meaning
um you know the flow on the bottom is
slower the flow above it is a little
faster a little faster a little faster
until the free stream you know the
really really fast flow out here but
it's layered and it's kind of steady
it's not bumpy or moving it's just kind
of stably stratified slower flow on the
bottom faster flow on top and and so you
can essentially see that the the
velocity profile if I pick a point here
then the velocity here is slow
um kind of slow and eventually increases
to the steady state so this is like the
flow velocity at these points and this
is what we call a boundary layer profile
and at some point you start getting you
know turbulence which is really messy
and
um erratic and you get a different
profile and so this is kind of
approximately linear Dynamics and this
is very non-linear and so
um let's draw another little Vortex
every every happy Vortex deserves a
friend
um
and so you get this transition to
turbulence at some point in this
boundary layer
is that this system the the linearized
Dynamics the linearized Dynamics about
this
um this this is called laminar over here
so we have laminar
and turbulent
I would argue that if you and there is a
solution there is mathematically a
solution where the entire flow over the
entire Wing is in fact laminar kind of
stably stratified
but it is unstable at some flow velocity
at some position uh on this Wing kind of
turbulence gets excited this instability
gets excited uh and non-linearities you
know plus non-linear terms start getting
excited here in the fluid flow equations
but there is a horized version of of
that that solution
uh that has a laminar a laminar solution
and so flows like this are what are
called Shear flows because you notice
that the flow is slow and then faster
and then faster this kind of profile
here where I have
a linearly increasing flow velocity so
this is literally
um some X position here this is some y
position here and this is my flow
velocity U
when I have this large gradient of the
flow velocity a large partial U partial
y when this is large this is called a
Shear dominated flow and Shear dominated
flows tend to have linearizations that
are highly non-normal okay that is a
really important property in fluids
flows you can picture them flows that
have uh you know really fast flows on
top of really slow flows they're going
to want to kind of roil up and form this
turbulence this is called a Shear
dominated flow
and specifically if I look at this
little area patch here that I drew
before
the fluid flow equations the Navy or
Stokes equations
um at least you know in in liquid water
or at low velocities in air are
incompressible
which means that the determinant of my a
matrix is always going to have to equal
one because fluid you know can stretch
but it can't change its volume liquid
can't change its volume
and so a little unit Square
with area one is going to have to map
into another shape with area one
but these sheer flows they tend to
stretch out into these very kind of
can't I hope I can draw it these very
kind of oblong uh very stretched very
sheared parallelograms so this still has
area one but this is highly sheared this
is a highly sheared
volume and literally this is what would
happen if you took this Cube this square
and you put it in this flow is that the
top part is going to move faster than
the bottom part and it's going to Shear
this square into this shape same thing
with a boundary layer if I put a little
square here a little imaginary Square
particles they're going to Shear as they
move forward
and those sheer flows that have again
very parallel eigenvectors of the a
matrix are non-normal and they're going
to give us this transient energy growth
this large increase in the energy or the
state value of that system before it
eventually dies off
and in some systems this is where it
gets really interesting you actually
have some fluid systems where the a
matrix the linearization of the Navy or
Stokes equation are actually stable at
all flow velocities so I mentioned this
before your pipe flow at home
you know when you turn on the tap so
flow is going let's make my flow blue
right you got nice clean water hopefully
coming in and out of this tap this
system is linearly stable at all flow
velocities so it'll only have stable
eigenvalues
but what happens is
that this is a highly sheared flow the
flow on the near the walls is much
slower than the flow in the middle you
you literally have a flow profile
that looks like you know like that so
it's much faster in the middle than on
the outside and that creates these large
shears and makes the Dynamics a highly
non-normal
and so those systems specifically look
like uh have responses that look like
this uh this behavior and specifically
if I have little roughness on the the
walls of my pipe and pretty much all
pipes have some amount of roughness on
them you know maybe they're made of
metal or concrete or whatever even even
polished metal microscopically is going
to have little elements of roughness and
these little elements of roughness give
me an initial perturbation an initial
perturbation and sometimes that
perturbation can grow large enough to
actually create and excite non-linear
terms in the Navy or Stokes equations so
these little linear perturbations can
excite the system uh and into full-blown
turbulence
and so the picture I draw here that I
kind of like is that you have either you
know time or space on this axis
and we have kind of the intensity of a
disturbance literally the intensity
of a disturbance
like from this wall element here
and if it's a small enough disturbance
and my flow is slow enough so the shear
is not too bad so the a is not so
non-normal then what I'm going to get is
I'm actually going to have that
disturbance increase and then eventually
die out it'll actually still be a
laminar flow so if you only turn your
tap on you know a quarter of the way or
half of the way maybe the flow is low
enough and the shear is low enough that
a is not so non-normal and this this
perturbation kind of dies out into case
so you still have laminar flow out of
your TAP smooth kind of flow
but at some point if my disturbance is
large enough if it's a rough enough wall
or my flow velocity is large enough so
the shear is really large so my a matrix
is highly non-normal
then essentially this will
increase large enough and instead of
decaying down to zero there is this
threshold of instability this kind of uh
maybe I'll draw it here this is an
instability threshold a transition
threshold
this is called the transition threshold
where Above This
non-linear Dynamics in the Navy air
Stokes equations because the Navy or
Stokes equations are not actually linear
we just linearize them about the laminar
solution at some point these
perturbations become big enough that my
small angle approximation my little
Delta perturbations are small
approximation no longer holds these are
big and so they excite non-linearities
and my system goes into self-sustained
turbulence so this is kind of
self-sustained turbulence self-sustained
turbulence
and this is why the water coming out of
your tap if you turn up the tap really
really high volume or if you have a
really really rough pipe even though the
equations are linearly stable at all
flow velocities at some magnitude of
disturbance or at some flow velocity
these perturbations grow past a point
where they excite non-linearities and
give you self-sustained turbulence
then called bypass transition to
turbulence so instead of having a
non-linear or an instability an a which
is actually what happens here this is an
instability you can have an actually
stable system but through this
non-normal energy growth these
perturbation energies can grow larger
and larger until they excite
non-linearities and get into
self-sustained turbulence so very very
cool stuff and this is actually only
relatively recently been understood at
least in the grand scheme of things
maybe in the last you know handful of
decades do we really kind of understand
how this is happening so that's kind of
exciting
uh okay is there anything else I want to
tell you um so these are very very
important systems actually where you
have and it's very common if I just
randomly draw an a matrix out of a hat
chances are this is not going to be true
and it will be a non-normal a matrix and
there will be at least some degree
of non-normality and parallelness of my
of my eigenvectors
at least in fluids it has this very
intuitive interpretable physical uh
interpretation of
flows that have a lot of Shear are going
to have
um literally you know volumes in face
space are going to get sheared into
these very oblique
shapes and that's going to give me this
transient energy growth which could
excite non-linearities and turbulence
okay uh that was a lot
um one of my favorite topics in fluids
and in the next lecture I'm going to
show you mathematically what is the
property of these parallel eigenvectors
and these nearly equal eigenvalues that
gets me close to what I'm calling
degeneracy that gives me something that
looks like these secular terms so I'll
tell you what these secular terms are in
the next lecture and we'll kind of
understand more mathematically uh how to
take you know either the a t of this
Matrix and why this is such a problem
all right that's all coming up soon stay
tuned thank you
[Music]
foreign